vous vivez entièrement à l'ancienne
et ça me plaît
[Musique]
ici dans la plus vieille vigne de la
propriété oui
556 alors la zone 121 ans exactement et
personne n'y a jamais touché
de père en fils on a on n'arrache pas
cette ligne nous voulons voir combien de
temps que ça peut vivre en tout cas vous
vous venez tout seul
je remplace les petits qui crèves voilà
et encore pas tous
parce que toute façon vous êtes vous un
homme attaché aux traditions
tout le passé tout ce qui a fait qui
faisait la joie de vivre maintenant
[Musique]
il s'appelle comment il s'appelle bonbon
rien boire là
le dernier à clé encore sur les champs
oui c'est l'heure du soleil c'est la
vraie
mais c'est pas gênant dans la vie
quotidienne parce que si vous prenez le
train par exemple c'est pas c'est pas
l'heure de tout le monde je ne prends
jamais le train je ne monte jamais en
voiture je me promène en vélo ou avec le
cheval c'est tout
vous vivez entièrement à l'ancienne
et ça me plaît je ne pourrais pas
supporter de vivre je suppose dans une
maison ou n'aurait que des des
cuisinières électriques du chauffage
Amazon
degrés dans la cuisine l'ouverture et
j'ai même trop chaud et vous vous
habillez à l'ancienne aussi oui oui oui
et alors
c'est à dire je porte les costumes que
porter comme pour terminer le sol
je portais les chemises sans colle le
dimanche je mets le focale en celluloïde
ça je ne sais dur mais enfin olympique
j'espère que c'est une paire de
chaussettes je ne sais pas ce que c'est
que des sous les Janis des souliers je
n'ai pas mis de solides depuis le
mariage de ma soeur et vous assure que
je les avais pas attachés c'est parti
pendant le dîner
je mets des feutres en couleur en
semaine et le dimanche pour aller à la
messe il met des feutres noires et s'il
pleut je mets ça va
[Musique]
pour ouvrir le plus près possible de la
nature quand vous vivez très près de
Dieu c'est certain c'est là qu'il faut
en revenir comprenez
[Musique]